abrir la puerta a la ayuda humanitaria
esta es la razón esgrimida por los
rebeldes del Frente de Liberación
Popular de Tigre para explicar su salida
de dos áreas clave de Etiopía acabamos
de completar la retirada de nuestras
fuerzas de las dos regiones de Amara y
hafar al hacerlo creemos que hemos
eliminado cualquier excusa de la
comunidad internacional para justificar
su inacción cuando se trata de presionar
a vidamed y sus socios regionales en
Afganistán este anuncio es difícil de
verificar sin existir una fuente
independiente en la zona está retirada
fue exigencia del gobierno de había me
como requisito previo a cualquier
negociación pero hasta ahora había sido
calificado de impensable por los
rebeldes que afirmaron hace unas semanas
estar a solo 200 kilómetros de la
capital Addis Abeba pero a finales de
noviembre hubo una reversión de la
situación las tropas federales lideraron
una contraofensiva y el gobierno reclamo
varias victorias transmitidas por la
televisión estatal en poco más de un año
el conflicto ha dejado varios miles de y
más de dos millones de desplazados
el impacto humanitario del conflicto es
cada vez más dramático la inseguridad
alimentaria aguda afecta ahora más de
9,4 millones de personas en el norte de
tío Pía según la Oficina de Asuntos
Humanitarios de las Naciones Unidas solo
en Tigre
5,2 millones de personas casi el 90% en
la población que la necesitan el viernes
la ONU dio luz verde a un mecanismo
internacional para investigar los abusos
cometidos por todas las partes en
Etiopía